If the plethora of Marvel and DC films aren't
enough to soothe your superhero cravings,
you might want to see what other countries
have to offer.
Sure, these movies might not be as technically
impressive as the superpowered blockbusters
we're used to—but they feature enough culture
shock quirks to warrant a watch.
Let's take a trip across the globe and see
the strangest superhero films released outside
the United States.
Guardians - Russia
If you thought Guardians of the Galaxy needed
less humor and more super ripped bears, you'll
be thrilled with 2017's Guardians.
This Russian superhero epic looks like a knockoff
Marvel film with about a quarter of the budget.
There's acrobatic fighting, insane weapons,
and gorgeous people doing battle — all the
modern superhero hallmarks.
But Russia really brings the weird with Ursus
the werebear.
Unlike werewolves, Ursus doesn't have to wait
for a full moon to take bear form — he can
do it whenever he wants.
Or if he'd rather just be half-man, half-bear,
that's an option too — which leads to the
best moment of the trailer: seeing a man-bear
fire off a machine gun.
The Heroic Trio - China
When it comes to female superheroes, China
has us beat.
1992's The Heroic Trio is about a squad of
three superpowered women united to stop a
supernatural villain whose main goal is to
find a king for China.
He's kidnapped 18 male babies, and one will
become the ruler of the land; the others will
be groomed to form an army of killers.
The plot may sound a little bit odd, but if
you want to see flying motorcycles cut in
half, or a leather-clad lady riding a dynamite-fueled
barrel, your only choice is The Heroic Trio.
Three Supermen and Mad Girl - Turkey
Why settle for one Superman when you can have
three?
Turkey has made a lot of knockoff superhero
movies, but perhaps the strangest is 1973's
Three Supermen and Mad Girl.
Three low-rent Superman knock-offs fight off
an evil foe named Mad Girl ... for some reason.
There's also an old fashioned, definitely-made-from-a-cardboard-box
robot who plagues our heroes with his death
ray.
Will our Supermen prevail?
Is that actually supposed to be the devil,
or just a guy in a mask?
Watch all 65 minutes to find out!
Zebraman - Japan
If you combined Breaking Bad with Kick-Ass,
you'd get 2004's Japanese action comedy Zebraman.
It's about a failed teacher and family man
who escapes from his depressing life by secretly
dressing up like an unpopular 1970s TV superhero
called — you guessed it — Zebraman.
But unlike Kick-Ass, the protagonist of Zebraman
soon learns he actually does have superpowers,
so he uses them to defeat alien-possessed
baddies set on conquering Earth.
RA.One - India
It looks a lot like some kind of Indian Iron
Man, but 2010's RA.One is not a blatant Marvel
copy.
It's more like a Tron/Iron Man mashup.
A programmer creates a video game with a very
powerful villain named RA.One.
Unfortunately, the villain escapes the game
and enters the real world, so the game's creator
must transform into a hero named G. One to
defeat him.
Chakra the Invincible - India
Did you know Marvel legend Stan Lee also created
an Indian superhero?
Chakra the Invincible is Lee's first venture
outside the U.S., and so far, the hero has
an animated film for Cartoon Network India
and a live-action version in development.
The story is about Raju Rai, a young kid who
tries on a blue bodysuit that gives him spiritually-derived
superpowers that turn him into Chakra the
Invincible, protector of Mumbai.
The Return of Captain Invincible - Australia
The plot of 1983's Australian superhero parody
The Return of Captain Invincible is unusual,
to say the least.
Alan Arkin's Captain Invincible is America's
go-to superhero during World War II, but during
the McCarthy trials, he's ruled a danger to
the country and no longer allowed to fight
crime.
Cut to the '80s, when a villain played by
Christopher Lee gets control of a hypno-ray
that causes people to laugh uncontrollably.
The U.S. must find Captain Invincible, who's
now a terrible drunk hiding out in Australia.
Also, it's a musical …
"Where angels fear to tread / I say, 'Choose
your booze!
Let's hit the red eye!'"
Mr. and Mrs. Incredible - Hong Kong
2011's Hong Kong action comedy Mr. and Mrs.
Incredible is about a retired husband-and-wife
crime fighting duo who have to deal with the
issues of a normal life.
Are they inspired by The Incredibles, Pixar's
2004 film about a retired superhero family?
Probably!
But the folks at Pixar haven't sued anybody
over it yet — maybe they're fans?
Unlike the family favorite, the Hong Kong
version partly revolves around the husband
losing interest in sex with his wife until
a new hot lady comes to town.
But husband Gazer Warrior, who shoots lightning
from his eyes, and wife Aroma Woman, who puts
men into a trance with her alluring odor,
end up rekindling the spark in their marriage—all
while wrangling their giant goldfish.
Rendel - Finland
Perhaps the most conventional film on this
list, Finland's Rendel is about Punisher-like
figure looking to take down a criminal organization
that murdered his family.
Not much is known about the Nordic nation's
first masked vigilante, but the trailer for
the Indiegogo-financed flick, due out in the
Fall of 2017, hints at a dark, slick dystopian
tale with production values that belie its
humble origins.
We do know for certain it's the only superhero
movie with official promotional condoms.
Your move, Deadpool 2.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!